des infirmiers de bloc pract à la main
c'est plutôt rare en colère ils
réclament le paiement d'une prime de 50
euros net par mois résultat d'un accord
obtenu il ya près de 20 ans mais sur
dijon il ne voit toujours rien venir
on devrait la touche et depuis 2002 or
le chu de dijon à s'arrête de la payer
aux infirmiers dès qu'ils ont le diplôme
d'infirmier blocs opératoires ce qui
peut représenter des sommes allant
jusqu'à 16 mille euros selon
l'ancienneté des infirmiers à dijon ils
sont 25 infirmiers de bloc diplômés
d'état selon les grévistes
le chu fonctionnerait avec plus de 70
infirmiers de soins généraux vous êtes
soigné aujourd'hui au bloc opératoire
par des infirmiers qui ne sont pas
formés comme les hôpitaux ne ne veulent
pas former les infirmiers de bloc
opératoire comme nous ça leur revient
trop cher alors qu'ils peuvent mettre du
personnel non formé
contrairement généralistes les
infirmiers diplômés d'état en bloc
opératoire ne touchent pas cette
bonification alors qu'ils sont
spécialisés une bizarre est liée au flou
du décret publié en 2002 pour les
infirmiers grévistes la justice
lorsqu'on a suivi une formation de 18
mois moi je suis diplômée depuis un an
et je perds de l'argent le pichoux
diplômés j'ai gagné 25 euros de part mon
diplôme mais vu que cette prime a été
supprimé ça m'a fait 60 euros en moins
une délégation a été finalement reçue
par la direction
une direction qui a refusé notre demande
d'interview et s'est exprimée par
communiqué le chu de dijon ne peut en
l'état des textes faire bénéficier ces
catégories professionnelles de cette
nouvelle bonification indiciaire
il s'agit d'une problématique nationale
que la direction à faire remonter à
plusieurs reprises à dijon les
infirmiers font bloc et ont déposé un
recours au tribunal administratif
il pourrait être à nouveau en grève
demain matin